[Musique]
et
maman
[Musique]
bienvenue sur le plateau interdit
d'interdire
émission spéciale affrontements puisque
je reçois abdel raouf dafri le
scénariste du prophète de merine et de
braquo pour la sortie de k sang impur
son premier film en tant que réalisateur
ça se passe pendant la guerre d'algérie
galles bio danault qui joue la journée
de la jupe au théâtre des béliers
l'histoire d'une prof qui prend ses
élèves en otage question carisaie pour
son livre la folie fisher sur le
champion d'échecs américain bobby
fischer le premier à avoir mis fin à la
suprématie des soviétiques pendant la
guerre froide et le pianiste selim
mazari pour son album consacré aux
variations de méthode et il y sera
question évidemment de napoléon et de
leurs affrontements
mais commençons tout de suite par notre
époque qu'est ce qui la caractérise
voici leurs réponses en images on
commence par là votre question en
carisaie alors ça c'est le le mémorial
du 11-septembre le rat on leur a reconnu
recettes non seulement je te vends parce
que c'est mon nom c'est une image qui en
fait une image un peu anciennes parce
que
il n'y a pas encore beaucoup d'art moi
j'ai eu la chance de voir le mémorial il
ya quelques mois et sa voix lasse à
bouquin lane où se dressait le world
trade center autrui s'est effondré ou
jérémy cia les bercer et s'éteint c'est
un lieu de paix de recueillement c'est
un lieu qui est très très touchant très
émouvant très angoissant aussi on
rappelle c'est un deux bassins à
l'emplacement des anciennes tours sur
les côtés sont gravés le nom de toutes
les victimes et au milieu il ya un puits
est en fait se cuit dans ce puits tombe
ça puits sans fond car qu'elle tombe
tombe de l'eau et c'est un projet qui a
été assez critiqué par certains parce
que cette eau qui tombe sans fond ça
rappelait vous ça pouvait rappeler ceux
qui étaient les tours qui tombait qui
tombait sans fond et ceux qui privilégié
au contraire la résilience pour qu'on
ait un mot à la mode était très été très
gêné par sept par cette image
franchement je trouve que ça encore une
fois c'est un lieu qui est très beau qui
dit beaucoup de choses sur notre époque
qui dit beaucoup de choses sur nous
au-delà de cette de cette tragédie
et puis il ya tous ces arbres et au
milieu de ces arbres il ya le survival
c'est le dernier larron qui a été
retrouvé sous les décombres que les les
les américains ont conservé ont replanté
et chaque année il ya un plan de cet
arbre qui est donnée à deux ou trois
villes qui ont connu des subi des
attentats voilà donc je crois que c'est
une image qui dit beaucoup de choses de
notre époque et juste pour terminer moi
dans mon souvenir c'est la première fois
il n'y avait pas encore de chaînes
d'info en continu comme comme
aujourd'hui et c'est la première fois
qu'on voyait en boucle on était
littéralement sidéré la mémoire vous
trahit il y avait déjà un avion beaucoup
alors par la gare with one x 90 4 mais
en france il y avait pas de chaîne
d'amour en continu et moi je me souviens
très bien je pense que chacun se
souvient très bien de ce jour là et on
regardait ces images en boucle on était
totalement tétanisée abdel raouf dafri
de tri mais j'avoue la boétie de calor 7
cette image cette photo a été prise par
mario cruz qui est un photographe
portugais et
c'est une c'est cette image c'est un
fleuve contrairement à ce qu'on pourrait
croire c'est un fleuve c'est le fleuve
pasig pas de sig à manille aux
philippines
le gamin qu'on voit est vivant il dort
sur un matelas qui entre guillemets
flotte sur ce fleuve et son job à ce
gamin pour survivre c'est de récupérer
des objets recyclables et il faut savoir
que le fleuve pasig est tellement pollué
qu'il a été déclarée biologiquement
morts dans les années 90 et il y à des
endroits où il y a tellement d'ordures
au tour et ce gamin que ce gamin peut se
déplacer parce que là l'image c'est une
photo que le gamma peut marcher sur les
eaux sûr sûr sûr les sur les ordures et
que sans avoir les pieds mouillés
tellement le fleuve est pollué et je
trouve que ça en dit long sur sur
l'époque d'aujourd'hui on parle
énormément d'écologie et l'or c'est une
image sordide et ironique parce que son
job pour pouvoir survivre c'est heureux
récupérer des objets recyclables
intéressant salim avarie mon image
finalement assez classique
c'est un poussin c'est un poussin
exactement on est en 740 c'est les
bergers d'arcadie qui regarde une tombe
et d'ailleurs si on peut tout de suite
faire un parallèle avec l'écologie
puisque c'est une tong qui dit moi aussi
je vivais en arcadie moi aussi je donc
cdd c'est d'héberger le berger c'est là
le thème pastoral des gens près de la
nature
une certaine insouciance qui s'engagent
et qui regarde quelqu'un qui a vécu
donc c'est aussi le passé c'est la mort
peut aussi contempler l'avenir là dessus
arcadis est un pays qui n'existe pas
c'est évidemment un endroit fantasmer un
endroit où on pourrait imaginer
maintenant ce que finalement les rares
endroits en france ou en france dans le
monde dans lequel l'homme n'a pas
d'empreintes
l'homme n'a pas eu d'empreintes c'est
peut-être ça finalement notre arcade y
est à l'heure actuelle à une heure où
effectivement la planète meurt on nous
le rappelons nous le rappellent tous les
jours je trouvais ça intéressant de me
plonger sur un tableau tout à fait
classique
voilà c'est une des interprétations et
une d un des angles sur lequel on peut
le regarder je vous rassure la planète
ne meurt pas il se réchauffe mais elle
ne meurt pas ils vont actuellement ce
qui pourrait mourir c'est nous
vous l'êtes un peu alarmiste mais la
planète nous sur me voir et bruel aussi
c'est l'été on est dans cette thématique
là mais parce que d'abord ce que je
trouve beau dans cette
dans cette photo c'est cette jeunesse
qui se réunit qui se mobilisent autour
de la même cause je trouve que c'est
plein d'esprit les manifestations pour
le clip bah oui c'est la marche pour le
climat je trouve que c'est beau de voir
tous ces jeunes qui s'élève ensemble et
unis pour la même cause qui est la cause
de notre terre dont on est purement
locataires on a un peu tendance à
l'oublier on a ri en sortant il succède
au très exactement restera là exactement
on a un peu tendance à penser qu'on a un
peu les propriétaires mais non elle nous
le rappelle d'ailleurs en ce moment de
plus en plus et même si évidemment les
points de vue sont différents et
peut-être pas toujours aussi alarmiste
et heureusement sur la fin du monde est
pour demain mais en tout cas il ya une
prise de conscience générale qui se met
en place et ça ça je trouve que c'est
plutôt c'est plutôt une bonne chose
voilà parce que si on peut tous se
réunir autour d'une cause commune qui
est la préservation de notre
environnement et de et de nos moyens de
subsistance partout dans le monde toutes
les photos qu'on a vu et la photo de ce
petit garçon qui doit ramasser les
ordures en face absolument terrifiant
alpha yaya
comment les grandes cascades victoria
aussi qu'ils sont complètement asséché
alors que ça n'était jamais arrivé
enfin il ya quand même des endroits dans
le monde où on peut être pour ou contre
cette idée de réchauffement climatique
qui a des conséquences absolument
terrible sur notre planète mais en tout
cas force est de constater que quand
même ya plein d'endroits dans le monde
où où ça a des conséquences terribles
quoi et ça se rapproche et bien
commençons
[Musique]
abdel raouf dafri votre premier film en
tant que réalisateur sort en salles il
s'intitule qu'un sang impur
il se passe pendant la guerre d'algérie
pourquoi pendant la guerre d'algérie
d'ailleurs vous auriez très bien pu
raconter la même histoire qui se passe
aujourd'hui en syrie en irak avec des
chenaux les films sur sur le terrorisme
mais ce qui se passe actuellement
on n'a pas encore assez de données je
pense et de recul pour ce pour pouvoir
appréhender le sujet sur la guerre
d'algérie c'est très simple mes parents
sont algériens et ils sont arrivés en 63
en france à marseille et vous je suis né
en 64 mes parents étaient analphabètes
ils n'avaient pas hésité pas politiser
mon père n'était pas particulièrement
idéologisé c'était un criminel de droit
commun est un type fast et une racaille
hâtif assez dangereux qui ne pensaient
qu'à sa survivance
d'ailleurs pendant la guerre il
accueillait il avait été appelé par là
pour la conscription parce que ont ils
étaient français certes d'origine
indigène sur le sol système de
l'indigénat et du colonialisme
mais quand il s'agissait de faire la
guerre on les appelait donc ils devaient
faire leur service et mon père n'était
pas question qu'ils fassent son service
militaire ou qui se battent pour un
drapeau il s'est sauvé en allemagne et
il avait un plan formidable j'épouse une
allemande
je prends la nationalité allemande j'ai
fait des gosses et j'en entends plus
parler de la france et de l'algérie
bon son plan a foiré puisque en la
renvoyant d'algérie et je m'appelle
abdelraouf et pas une goutte
bien sûr toute cette histoire de la
guerre d'algérie chez nous on n'en
parlait pas puisque mes parents
n'étaient ni politiser ni alphabétisés
et je précise d'ailleurs que cette
histoire ne raconte pas du tout
l'histoire de vos parents n'ont pu et
j'ai vu aussi un matériau scénographique
assez intéressant puisque aujourd'hui on
peut raconter des fictions sur les
banlieues on peut raconter comme les
américains l'ont fait des films sur la
guerre du vietnam qui est un traumatisme
pour les états unis jusqu'à aujourd'hui
et comme j'étais d'origine algérienne
comme je suis d'origine algérienne je me
suis dit bon je vais parler du conflit
que je connais le mieux c'est et qui se
rapproche le plus de mes origines
mes parents l'algérie si j'avais été
vietnamien bien sûr j'aurais situer
l'action de mon film en a d'ailleurs ce
film peut faire penser à un peu quel xna
avec olivier gourmet dans le rôle avec
le crâne rasé dans le rôle de maman
brando à la fast une quête comme ça oui
alors on m'a fait on m'a fait la
réflexion mais en fait mon film et tous
les personnages qui sont à l'intérieur
la façon dont ils sont grimés et
habillés sont inspirés de personnages
qui ont existé dans le cas d'olivier
gourmet le personnage de lumière simon
de lumière il est inspiré d'un colonel
qui s'appelle le colonel pierre château
jobert et qui était un officier en
indochine à l'officier français qui
était aussi en algérie et pierre château
jaubert j'ai fait il a une tête assez
particulière et les chaussures le dessus
et il a une barbe qui démarre là alors
que le crâne est totalement lisse et
j'avais dit j'avais dit à la maquilleuse
je veux qu olivier et cette tête là et
c'est une référence à pierre château
jobin la france prend du tout été trahir
à la france évitera la france château
jaubert pour joindre les os alors à pour
rejoindre l'ouest n'ont pas les armes
on regarde tout de suite la
bande-annonce de dunks de qu'un sang
impur
[Musique]
je veux que vous alliez dans les aurès
nememcha et que vous trouviez le corps
du colonel simon de lumière dans moins
de six jours le napalm à aura tout
brûler
c'est au cours de solution tout à vis de
désobéir est le seul de mes ordres futur
et sur place
qu'est ce qu'on ferait pas pour son pays
mais paris c'est quoi la rade là-bas
tentative d'évasion et un refus de
s'intégrer à la chorale
nous sommes encore ce que c'est la
miséricorde mon colonel
ce drame n'est ce métier doit mettre son
côté le prix ap
rentrez tout quoi je suis capable quand
je mets mon corps de côté
c'est un film particulièrement sévère
avec les français que vous avez réalisé
abdellah ofda free on voit par exemple
quelques combattants du fln qui
suffisent à décimer un poste de parra
comme dans le désert et il n'y a jamais
eu autant de morts je crois français
d'un seul coup pendant toute cette
pendant toute cette guerre on a eu nous
les français on a on a perdu quelque
chose comme 35 à 40 mille personnes
là-bas et le tiers des gens qui sont
morts là bas d'ailleurs mon film leur
est dédiée ce et les jeunes appelés
français qu'on a envoyés au casse pipe
sans leur dire de quoi il s'agissait
ce sera des opérations de maintien de
l'ordre juste on n'a jamais dansé une
guerre non mais et c'est s était logique
de ne pas prononcer le mot guerre c'est
très logique dans il faut il faut
remettre les choses dans le contexte
aujourd'hui
depuis notre balcon du 21e siècle on
peut facilement juger on
on a tous le recul les historiens ont
fait un très beau travail mais il faut
se remettre dans le contexte la france
l'algérie appartient à la france c'est
un département comme la bretagne
aujourd'hui où les hôtes france où la
région paca
c'est un département s'est ancrée dans
les esprits donc à partir du moment où
un département dans lequel il ya une
dizaine de personnes qui font sauter des
bombes
ça s'appelle du terrorisme alors par
lasser si on commence à reconnaître que
c'est une guerre si le gouvernement en
place reconnaît que c'est une guerre il
reconnaît implicitement que l'algérie ne
lui appartient pas donc il faut sur le
plan sémantique utilisée mais ce plan
c'est cette manière sémantique de parler
de gaulle pour vendre le pour ne pas
utiliser le terme indépendance quand il
fera un référendum il dira
autodétermination ce qui veut dire
exactement la même chose mais là où
j'entends vous êtes particulièrement
sévère avec les français parce qu'on y
voit un capitaine a ordonné à l'un de
ses hommes de tuer des enfants parce que
parce qu'il ya cette phrase les français
se couche pendant l'occupation tourner
les femmes à la libération
et puis ils boivent et il oublie ça nous
entendu et il recommence puisque en fait
la verrie dans votre film en tout cas
les français se conduisent en algérie
comme les allemands sont conduits en
france pendant l'occupation
les allemands et l'occupation allemande
n'est pas tout à fait comparable au
système colonial
parce que les allemands ne sont pas
venus ici pour transformer les français
en allemand déjà pour commencer et il
faut savoir que la colonisation
c'est clair que j'ai un peu plus la dent
dure mais pas contre les français
pas contre la france contre le système
de l'indigénat et du colonialisme
ça c'est très très clair pour moi donc
dès 1830 d'ailleurs nos plus grands
généraux et maréchaux français des
officiers de renom ont déclaré mais
publiquement et ils ont même écrit que
rester en algérie massacrer les
populations ne nous mènerait à rien de
bon au finish il vous pensez à qui or je
pense au maréchal lyautey je pense même
à bugeaud bugeaud qui a qui deviendra
gouverneur en algérie et avant ça on
l'avait envoyé se battre contre les
tribus d'abdelkader quand il revient de
sa mission contre les tribus
d'abdelkader il déclare en france mais
vraiment à la tribune devant les
politiques pour faire son rapport
il leur dit c'est un fardeau l'algérie
il ne faut pas y rester il n'y a rien de
bon en tirer et sa vague rêver les
finances du pays
donc bugeaud lui-même et pour qu'on se
retire d'algérie mais ce qui frappe hors
de votre film on va voir c'est un film
de commande ou c'est un peu comme on
pourrait le comparer à une glorieuse
master's de couler douce à devoir
d'animer reach douze salopards de robert
aldrich aux sept mercenaires de john
sturgess et le film de commando vous
prenez des hommes qui ont chacun une
spécialité des hommes et des femmes
puisqu'on est en 2019 en 2020 maintenant
mais en 2019 quand les tournées et ils
ont chacun une spécialité ils ont une
mission et ça donne votre film et or vos
héros ne sont pas français de souche
le capitaine est un allemand de la
légion étrangère
un belge un bel abbès inspiré d'un
office du de l'officier français du
sous-officier
oui le canal de partenaires qui est au
fait qu'est inspiré toujours moi je me
suis référé à mon histoire de france qui
est inspiré du sous-officier français le
plus décoré du vertige
siècle et ce sous-officier français
s'appelle roger van den berghe surnommé
van den à propos duquel le général de
lattre de tassigny déclara donnez moi
sans van den et je gagne l'indochine et
la mère de van den berg était juive
espagnol sera déporté à dara au après
avoir été dénoncés auprès de la gestapo
devinez par qui et son père étaient
belges flamands il mourra dans les
tranchées pendant la première guerre
mondiale et ce type et le sous-officier
français un héros une légende dans
l'armée française
le plus décoré du xxème siècle il ya
également un sénégalais il ya une
algérienne
une vietnamienne il ya quatre français
les mangas lé pa vienne a effectivement
elle explique d'ailleurs le seul
français de souche d'asie rixe c'est
celui de droite qui est pas forcément le
plus malin et quel visage totalement
tatoué enfin c'est pas hasard si vous
avez préféré faire un conte bandeau et
que moins de france est possible
sans doute parce que la forme et par
horizon français ils sont tous français
le sénégal et son père s'était battu et
c'est inscrit dans le film il s'était
battue pendant la première guerre
mondiale il avait été décoré il a gagné
la crosse guerre breitner a fait la
seconde guerre mondiale et il a
brillamment servi la france en indochine
d'ailleurs c'est par son sang versé
qu'il est devenu français
la mangue était supplétifs et sa famille
son père et son frère sont morts à dien
bien phu donc pour moi être français
c'est pas être forcément blanc avec un
nom à particule les noirs les arabes les
les italiens les portugais les espagnols
qui sont qui ont amené qui sont venus en
france qui ont immigré ici pour
travailler sont devenus français et à
partir du moment où on s'est battus sous
les couleurs de la france quand on est
sénégalais de naissance d'origine c'est
à dire qu'on était un supplétif comme
les mangues ou comme l'ont été les
harkis à partir de ce moment là où on a
pris les armes pour défendre la patrie
et la bannière française on est français
maintenant si on pense que français
c'est forcément être blanc catholique
on revient à une époque un peu spécial
il ya eu là les cités qui passe de raouf
dafri y ait une autre phrase dans votre
dans votre film x y en a plusieurs à
elles sont souvent bien décrites c'est
votre premier héritier il faut le
reconnaître nous avons rendu les gens
aussi barbare que nous ça c'est pas de
moi c'est un français qui le dira
oui c'est un français qui le dit dans
mon film mais c'est la phrase d'alexis
de tocqueville et alexis de tocqueville
a déclaré après les guerres d'abdelkader
et les enfumades de bugeaud et les
massacres
il faut savoir que quand nous sommes
arrivés en 1830 il y avait trois
millions de berbères en algérie appelé
les arabes et berbères bon ou des locaux
les autochtones
voilà il y en avait 3 millions en 1848
il y en a plus que deux millions qu'est
ce qui est arrivé aux millions manquants
ils sont partis à londres en passant de
marca les noms donc il faut savoir que
tocqueville a fait cette déclaration
et ça m'amusait c'est mon côté pervers
de la mettre dans la bouche d'un de mes
personnes verrière phrase lourde de sens
trop de sang a coulé les arabes nous
n'oublierons jamais les français n'ont
plus cette guerre ne mourra jamais vous
pensez qu on la continue encore
aujourd'hui du côté algérien non quand
vous allez en algérie ils ont ils ont
tourné la page comme disait boumédiène
quand il a reçu vallée valéry giscard
d'estaing
il a dit nous tournons la page mais nous
ne la déchire on pas ça c est une phrase
au filet les fraudeurs vont le fil
continu en france si je vois les
commentaires sur les réseaux sociaux
liés à mon film de la part de gens bien
gaulois avec des pseudos genre charles
martel bon ils disent j'ai eu des
commandes et j'ai lu des commentaires
qui m'ont beaucoup amusé vu le nom du
réalisateur on sait de quel côté ça va
on sait de quel côté va sa sensibilité
donc je n'irai pas voir un film de croo
y bon ok pourquoi pas évidemment en 2020
le film d'albert d'abdel raouf dafri
s'intitule qu'un sang impur et il sort
demain en salles
[Musique]
gal bio dano vous jouer tous les soirs
la journée de la jupe de jean paul
lilienfeld au théâtre des béliers est
une adaptation du téléfilm avec isabelle
adjani qui date de 2008 cette fois s'est
mise en scène par frédéric fages
c'est de plus en plus souvent qu'on voit
des films adaptés au théâtre comment
expliquez vous est ce que c'est parce
qu'on manque d'auteurs de théâtre ou
parce que c'est plus facile à vendre
parce qu'on en a déjà parlé et que c'est
un film non je crois pas je crois que je
crois que il ya des adaptations d'abord
plus ou moins réussie parce qu'il ya des
sujets qui se prêtent plus ou moins
enfin en tout cas des contextes qui se
prêtent plus ou moins à l'adaptation
je dirais que la journée de la jupe se
prêtait particulièrement bien cette
adaptation parce qu'un seul nick lowe
mois l'existence de l'extérieur déjà
dans le film mais il ya vraiment ce huis
clos 7 entre la prof et ses élèves qui
étaient particulièrement faciles à
adapter au théâtre finalement parce est
une société plus facile que ben-hur
qu'on a aussi oui tout est vide bien sûr
mais il faut d'autres films c'est sûr
qu'ils sont plus compliquées de par leur
contexte je sais pas si c'est parce
qu'on vende auteurs dont je pense qu'on
a pas mal de bons auteurs commencé quand
même mais mais je pense que peut-être
parfois quand on veut parler de sujets
un peu fort et un peu percutant au
théâtre c'est plus facile quand il ya
déjà eu une ouverture au cinéma parce
que je pense qu'aujourd'hui peut-être
dans le cadre privé parisien alors qu'il
n'y a pas vraiment bocci beaucoup de
belles choses qui se font c'est très
foisonnant mais c'est plus compliqué
d'aller atteindre un public quand on a
des sujets un peu complexes comme celui
de la journée de la jupe
s'il n'y a pas eu cette ouverture et
cinématographique et cette médiatisation
avant la publicité avant qui bien sûr
finalement bien sûr vous êtes
aujourd'hui on va regarder tout de suite
la bande-annonce du spectacle
[Musique]
du tout envie de parler
c'est juste une rare je voulais pas
j'ai pas choisi
je me suis retrouvé avec une arme dans
la main pour me défendre
j'en étais le marché
ces enfants étaient devenus mes ennemis
on n'arrête pas de vous répéter que ça
va péter
on n'arrive pas à faire cours vous ne
faites rien je vous préviens que s'il
arrive quelque chose à ma copine je veux
que tout le monde sache que le principal
n'a rien fait que l'inspection n'a rien
fait c'est pas un hasard si ça tombe sur
elle
on sait tous que la limite raciste non
il suffit juste de savoir leur parler
c'est tout ben elle est fragile déjà sur
le plan pédagogique ses limites
elle est un peu buté quoi plusieurs fois
je lui ai dit qu'il n'était pas
conseillé de venir en jupe dans cet
établissement que ce n'était pas neutre
de tenir compte du contexte alors bien
évidemment elle a fait exprès de venir
en jupe
[Musique]
c'est l'histoire on s'en souvient d'une
prof qui finit par prendre ses élèves en
otages vont leur faire étudier du
molière
alors on se souvient qu'elle est ça se
passe dans un quartier populaire un
quartier difficile dans un établissement
difficile on veut dire un quartier
populaire un établissement difficile
avec des élèves qui à priori ne
connaissent que la violence les injures
le racisme
oui enfin c'est un peu plus je dirais
complexe que ça se trouve que
l'adaptation enfin je trouve que quand
jean paul lilienfeld qui a fait ce film
et qui a signé dallas d'ailleurs
l'adaptation théâtrale
quand il a fait ce film il ya dix ans il
a eu beaucoup beaucoup de mal à monter
ce film parce que c'est un sujet qui
était déjà très présent mais qui n'était
pas politiquement correct donc c'est
pour ça que ça a été d'abord un téléfilm
et puis suite au succès du téléfilm ses
sorties en salles
je pense qu'aujourd'hui on en parle un
peu plus parce qu'on est obligé d'en
parler parce qu'il ya une médiatisation
aussi qu'on maîtrise moins donc avec les
réseaux sociaux il ya beaucoup de choses
qui filtrent on voit
des suicides de profs on voit des add on
voit tous les conflits qui peut y avoir
entre les profs et les élèves
aujourd'hui mais je pense que finalement
ce que j'aime moi dans la pièce et qui
était déjà assez présent dans le film
c'est qu'il n'y a pas de condamnation
en fait on condamne pas un côté ou
l'autre ccc la cartographie d'une
jeunesse aujourd'hui qui en cherchent de
repères qui n'ont pas de repères et qui
malheureusement sont sont aussi parfois
récupéré par des gens qui qu'ils leur
font croire des choses qui sont pas
justes il ya une défiance entre les
profs et les élèves aujourd'hui qui
finalement au fond n'a pas lieu d'être
moi j'ai beaucoup interrogé des profs
aussi j'ai aussi été en contact des
élèves on a joué cette pièce il ya
quelques temps à sarcelles devant 250
jeunes
c'était absolument génial et on a fait
un bond de plateau des changes avec eux
après on fait une pause on revient tout
de suite parlé de la journée de la jupe
un eagle bio dano
[Musique]
arrimé des pays africains à l'euro c'est
une évidence bêtise la france a intérêt
à maintenir de français parce que selon
le crr instruments qu'ils ont de
protection de ses intérêts économiques
en afrique
l'écho c'est quelque chose qui était
fait entre pays africains et sur lequel
la france et l'europe avait pas grand
chose à dire en question au ladakh fixe
avec nommé c'est est-ce que c'est pipe
mot n'est pas le sujet aujourd'hui en
afrique c'est pas d'avoir une inflation
à 2%
ces espèces de critères qu'on impose
alors c'est des critères de kira entre
guillemets d'économies matures à des
économies qui sont en développement
studio
[Musique]
dans ce livre on vous découvre
extrêmement proche de votre mari un
couple très fusionnelle à ce que vous
viviez un peu dans la peur avec tino
quai des menaces oui d intimidation
comme brûler les locaux oui mais un
assassinat vraiment jeune ans je pense
que j'y croyais pas ceux qui ont été
assassinés étaient les politiques du
journal il était l'âme de ce journal et
oui ils ont tué charlie je voulais pas
que tignes où ce soit une victime
je voulais pas que son nom soit associé
à 8 in youth la victime de charlie je
voulais que l'on se dise à tignes où le
grand dessinateur c'est ça qui est bien
avec un artiste c'est qu'un artiste ans
qu'on publie son travail l'artiste est
vivant
[Musique]
mes invités sont aujourd'hui abdel raouf
dafri lé réalisateur de 15 cents un pur
christian carisaie pour son livre la
folie fisher sur le champion du monde
d'échecs bobby fischer le pianiste
céline mazari pour son album consacré
variations de beethoven égale bio
danault qui joue la journée de la jupe
au théâtre des béliers la journée de la
jupe pour moi lorsque ça me fait penser
à un film qui s'appelait graine de
violence blackboard jungle en 1954 55 si
je me souviens bien
houas classe 84 qu'on a vu par la suite
alors ça s'était plutôt dans les années
80 c'est les années 50 84 c les années
80 la journée de la jupe c'est la
continuité dans le sens où à chaque fois
on nous montre des élèves de deux
milieux populaires qui ne veulent pas
apprendre ça a l'air d'être quelque
chose qui revient et qui continue et qui
à chaque fois stupéfie régulièrement
jugnot et rations et génération ce
serait des élèves des classes populaires
qui ne voudrait pas apprendre qu'ils
refuseraient d'apprendre est ce qu'il
n'ya pas ça est-ce que ça dépasse à
d'abord qui heurte cette professeure
dans cet établissement d'aujourd'hui je
sais pas si c'est parce qu'ils veulent
pas apprendre en fait c'est comme ça
qu'on les montre c'est comme ça qu'on
les montre mais c'est parce qu'on leur
on leur a fait croire que peut-être je
sais pas l'éducation était un bras armé
de l'état qui allait leur essayer de
leur faire peut-être un bourrage de
crâne je sais pas entrer et des
croyances sur aussi les rapports
profs-élèves ya aussi aussi un rapport
par rapport à l'autorité qui est
compliqué c'est pas simplement par le
fait par rapport au fait d'apprendre
c'est par rapport au fait que quelqu'un
leur impose des choses leurs deux noms
pareils dort blackboard jungle voilà qui
s'appelait en français c'est la jungle
du tableau noir moi je n'avais pas aimé
alors oui mais c'était dans l'air du
temps de blackboard jungle alors c'était
le racket qui était monté dans 13 84
c'était la drogue dans la journée de la
jupe c'est quoi c'est l'emprise de la
religion c'est il ya les dérives de
de la religion il ya les rapports
garçons filles qui sont très présents
avec un retour en arrière extrêmement
nettes tout ce qui se passe en fait est
qu'on ne soupçonne pas dans ces endroits
défavorisés que ce soit en province et
pas seulement en banlieue parce qu'on
parle beaucoup de la banlieue mais il ya
plein d'endroits en province moi j'ai
quelqu'un dans ma famille qui est prof à
roubaix dans un endroit compliqué sebha
est ce qui vit c'est à dire que c'est
une défiance est aussi une séparation
entre les garçons et les filles qui à
nouveau mais qui existe déjà la
maternelle il ya la maternelle vath
vielha métal ça va c'est dans l'est en
primaire et les garçons même accueillir
oui mais là il ya presque une défiance
par rapport à la féminité en fait est
injustement c'est ce que je comprends
pas dans la journée de la jupe
parce qu'en fait on leur reproche une
espèce de de virilité archaïque en fait
notion archaïque de la vie passée au
meneur en particulier mais je comprends
pas si on a une vision archaïque de la
viabilité pourquoi on veut pas que les
femmes soient en robe ou jupe devrait on
devrait pas vouloir qu'elle remporta
long mais mais qu'est ce qui les gêne
dans le fait que les femmes les jeunes
filles puissent causer les élèves aussi
soit en jupe
je pense que c'est un peu un prétexte en
fait je pense que ça va plus loin que ça
c'est tout ce qui touche à la féminité
et à tout ce qui touche à la sensualité
et tout ce qui touche à
à la prise de position peut-être aussi
de la femme dans la déplace plus forte à
une indépendance
mais là encore ce sont des croyances je
pense que c'est des choses si on creuse
un peu je pense pas que ce soit des
convictions profondes qu'ils ont qu'ils
soient personnels
je pense que c'est des choses qu'ils ont
entendu et qu'il récupère parce que là
encore ils ont perdu leurs repères et
qu'ils ont besoin de se raccrocher à des
choses et il se raccroche à ça ils ont
besoin de faire les caïds sas a existé
de tout temps et toujours les garçons
dans les classes dans la mémoire du
cinéma qui font un peu les caïds par
rapport aux filles il besoin de
rabaisser un peu mais je crois que ça se
sache se développe dangereusement et les
filles en sont conscientes d'ailleurs
c'est à dire qu'elle se camouflent aussi
beaucoup pour pouvoir avoir la paix pour
pouvoir être tranquille il ya aussi un
conflit elles elles ont de plus en plus
des attitudes de garçons même dans leur
langage
il suffit d goût d'écouter parfois les
jeunes filles dans le métro employés des
langages qu'avant on entendait aussi
quand même beaucoup beaucoup chez les
garçons voilà y'a une liasse il ya ce
besoin de d'exister par la force
oui on dirait qu'ils ne comprennent que
la force les insultes mais parce que par
ceux qui parce que c'est ce dont ils
sont entourés
malheureusement c'est à dire que moi
honnêtement pour reprendre l'exemple de
sarcelles il ya une petite fille à la
fin de sarcelles qui me dit madame
madame vous m'avez trop ému alors je dis
ah bah super elle me dit mais madame
avant d'être actrice vous étiez prof
alors j'ai dit mais non j'étais pas prof
eh bien vous devriez imagé dit la
prochaine fois avec un flingue bruit
mais aussi elle a vu aussi une prof est
vraiment c'est ce que j'essaye de
véhiculer dans le rôle de sonia bergerac
c'est une prof qui aime ses élèves alors
elle le fait mal elle le fait avec ses
moyens elle le fait avec les moyens que
peut être ne peuvent comprendre qui part
par la violence mais ce qu'elle veut
leur faire comprendre et s'est dit dans
la pièce c'est qu'aujourd'hui c'est par
l'éducation et on en parlait tout à
l'heure c'est par par l'appréhension
vous avez accès à ça vous avez le droit
à ça arrêtez de vous dit
que vous n'avez pas le droit ça vous
avez le droit à cette culture vous avez
droit à tout ça et c'est par là que
parce passe la liberté moi je vais vous
parler des histoires personnelles parce
que je trouve qu'elle est très marquante
j'ai ma belle-mère qui a géré yen qui
est arrivé en france dans les années 60
elle parlait pas français
c'est le cas d'ailleurs d'un du
personnage si son de la pièce el hajjami
pour qui la jouent à moitié allemande et
a beau dire oui et pourquoi ça me parle
tellement parce que cette femme qui ma
belle mère que je trouve d'un courage
incroyable depuis la mort de son mari
elle apprend à lire et écrire tout seul
elle vient d'avoir la nationalité
française elle est fière de ça elle a
élevé ses 14 enfants dans le respect de
la france et de sa de cette appartenance
tout en gardant ses origines et elle est
musulmane pratiquante élan et elle parle
de sa personne parce qu'elle vit ça de
façon très intime et elle pense que tout
le monde devrait le vivre de façon très
intime
la journée de la jupe ça défend tout ça
ça défend aussi elle me dit depuis que
j'ai appris à lire à écrire je suis
comme un oiseau qui est sorti de ma cage
et moi ça m'a fait des frissons ça
m'émeut
parce que je me dis en fait cette prof
elle veut donner ça assez à ses élèves
en apprenant et en ayant et en ayant
cette ouverture sur le monde par
l'écriture la lecture la musique la
littérature
vous allez être comme des oiseaux qui
sortent de votre cage mais non d'un
chien c'est ça qu'on veut leur donner
c'est cet amour là et si on pouvait
faire comprendre
moi je dis si on peut déjà quand ils
voient la pièce qui en est 5 6 10
peut-être qu'ils comprennent ça alors on
aura gagné quoi mais ce que je pensais
pas qu'ils l'ont déjà compris que vous
font ils sont peut-être que cinq six dix
à être comme dans la journée de la jupe
ça dépend des endroits mais c'est
tellement complexe est tellement
difficile aussi je trouve ça demande
beaucoup de courage à des jeunes de 17
ans de dire de s'opposer on a tellement
besoin d'appartenir à des groupes on se
sent plus fort aussi donc parfois on
accepte d'appartenir à des groupes où on
n'a pas peut-être obligatoirement ces
idéologies ou ses croyances mais on se
dit ben parce que j'ai la force et le
courage de m'opposer il faut être
carrément solide aussi pour le faire
quand on est jeune c'est au théâtre des
béliers tous les soirs la journée de la
jupe
mise en scène de frédéric fages
[Musique]
question carisaie vous venez de publier
la folie fischer chez alma éditeurs
c'est sur bobby fischer qui est devenu
champion du monde d'échecs en 1972 on a
gardé le souvenir d'un génie le plus
grand joueur d'échecs du xxème siècle
bichi fischer alors qu'il n'a ainsi
d'après tes surestimé en fait c'est en
lisant votre livre que je me suis dit
vous faut il a été complètement
surestimer ce bobby fischer après tout
alors c'est vrai qu'il était il a été le
premier américain au fonds est le seul
l'américain à remettre en cause la
suprématie des russes dans ce domaine
depuis d'ailleurs il n'ya eu canadien
est un norvégien tous les autres
champions du monde étaient soit des
russes soient des ressortissants
d'anciennes républiques soviétiques
il a été champion des états unis à 14
ans il a été grand maître international
à 15 ans il devient champion du monde à
29 ans pour la première fois un
américain contrat russe on est en pleine
guerre froide tout ça est très
symbolique 172 y gagne enfin il gagne
pas contre le meilleur champion russe de
tous les temps il vous gagne peut-être
même [ __ ] contre boris spassky qui est
sans doute l'un des plus faibles ou en
tout cas l'année mois de forts et
surtout il ne remettra jamais son titre
en jeu à partir de là il ne va plus
jamais jouer il va te refusé tous les
matches sauf une piteuse la piteuse
match revanche vingt ans plus tard en
yougoslavie est ce qui n'a pas été
surestimée bobby fischer non je crois
pas je crois que c'est un génie et en
tout cas d'abord lui se percevait comme
tel il à 188 premier à 188 on nettoie
génie premier point deuxième point il
était regardée comme comme un génie il a
une carrière en pointillé là vous avez
rappelé les moments où effectivement
petit à petit ils ceux qui se dirigent
vers ce championnat du monde qu'il va
gagner contre boris spassky qui n'est
peut-être pas le plus fort mais enfin
quand même maurice parce qu'il a battu
tous les autres points tendaient à cette
époque là je pense que l'appreil
harragas karpov et kasparov qui 500
couderc suis là pour le coup car pop je
pense que c'est le plus faible
kasparov enfin qu'à 20 ans il reste
cependant il reste pendant 20 ans mais
il devient champion du monde par par
défaut puisque d'ailleurs il veut des
cyclistes et de bobby fischer fischer
refuse de remettre en jeu son titre et
donc par abordons karpov et désigner le
champion du monde mais on ne sait pas ce
qu aurait pu donner un affrontement
fischer fischer car peuvent mais si si
si fischer refuse de remettre son titre
en jeu
je crois qu'on fonde aimant il a mais il
a cette question de tous les champions
du monde
une fois que vous êtes champion du monde
qu'est ce qui peut vous arriver qu est
ce que vous pouvez faire de mieux
non désolé d'être aussi muet à jouer et
un jour d'être battu par un plus jeune
parent plus fort et sa double fischer il
ne supporte pas ceci étant dans
l'histoire de des échecs c'est pas le
premier qui a des problèmes de
comportement et qui a des difficultés
avec les choses dans l'ordre a mis là il
n'y a pas que des problèmes de
comportement il est complètement
psychotique qui les parlent à nolhac
grave complet il est persuadé qu'il ya
des complots de la cia du kgb du mossad
fallu contre lui on les voit il entend
des voix il dort dans des couvertures de
survie fait protéger ses fenêtres parce
qu'il est effectivement persuadé que le
kgb mossad la cia le bombardement
don du sang c'est donc sonore et c'est
dans ce contexte là qui se présente
quand même à reykjavik
après beaucoup de beaucoup d'hésitation
grecs à 10 ans et leur championnat et la
62e du monde de 72 mais au moment de
l'ouverture du championnat du monde
tous les officiels sont là les officiels
américains sont là et c'est le seul qui
manque c'est bobby fischer ils pensent
qu'on ne viendra pas et est élu et voilà
la réalité je ne viendrai pas à ce que
parce que il est dans cette période de
crise
mais c'est là où on gueule et quand on
vous livre de votre livre on s'en
aperçoit on se dit mais au fond ce type
très fragile
peut-être été trop fragiles pour faire
une vraie carrière de champion d'échecs
pour moi il ne fait pas de carrière de
champion d'échecs il arrive aux
championnats du monde ils l'emportent
mais il ne leur joue jamais carrière
d'après champions déchets la cmm avant
il a passé plus de temps à refuser les
macarons dissolue mais est offert chaque
fois qu'il engage deux mois et s'il
était si génial que ça pousse à blanc
buzz qui a été tellement fragile et
tellement dingue on peut comprendre
qu'il n'ait pas été armé pour faire une
carrière
une vraie carrière de champion du monde
on va mais ce qui est ce qui est
bluffant c'est que chaque fois qu'il eux
qu'il revient parce qu'évidemment il
bataille contre lui-même il bataille
contre les autorités enfin bref et qui
bataille contre contre tout le monde et
donc il a des périodes comme ça où
pendant deux ou trois ans il joue plus
et chaque fois qu'il leur revient
jusqu'aux championnats du monde tout le
monde est bluffé par ses intuitions
géniales tout le monde est bluffé par
son jeu et ils l'emportent donc voilà
ccc évidemment quelqu'un
d'extraordinairement fragile
encore une fois comme il y en a eu
d'autres mais c'est quelqu'un lorsqu'il
est face à l'échiquier et être face à
l'échiquier ça sans doute quelque chose
de terrifiant
chaque fois qu'il est face à l'échiquier
et redevient un bobby fischer génial
sauf après dans la vie quand il va ils
vont faire enfin larves
enfin il va refuser de jouer après qu'il
a été champion du monde donc il va être
oublié mis sur le banc on va continuer
de championnat du monde sans lui ce sera
un karpov puis kasparov celui mai et
puis vingt ans plus tard pendant la
guerre en yougoslavie il
il dispute le match revanche contre
spassky comme si le seul avec qui
voulaient rejouer éternellement aux
championnats du monde c'était toujours
le même dans l'espace qui l'a vous le
dites vous même
il joue beaucoup moins bien ah non mais
là la joue mieux que ce qui m'est non
mais je vais pas terrible non mais là le
remake il est pathétique
ouais
ce pas ce qui est 100e joueur du monde
lui continue à faire des tournois parce
qu'entre temps
ce pass qui a perdu non seulement il a
perdu aux championnats du monde dont
quand ils rentrent en union soviétique
ça se passe évidemment très mal pour lui
mais surtout il a applaudi fischer parce
que ce pass qui lui-même à un moment
donné il est fasciné par il ya hélas une
fameuse sixième partie qui perd et on
est dans ce grand hall de reykjavik il
ya le silence se fait la partie est
terminée
espace qui se lève et l'applaudît son
adversaire et ça ça s'est jamais vu ça
on va lui faire payer donc il va finir
par quitter quitter l'union soviétique
il vit arriver à me dont il joue et
c'est bon il ya des problèmes de fric
fischer c'est la même chose il il a une
vie complètement chaotiques il est il et
il est il est dépressif il est exaltée
enfin ils passent de l'un à l'autre
et puis il ya un intermédiaire qui va se
mettre en tête de faire rejouer ce un
match un match revanche que fisher a
refusé après dix fois que quelques
années après le championnat du monde
tout le monde rêvait de la fiche c'est
comme dans la boxe on rêve toujours de
de reconduire la même la même affiche
et puis et puis finalement il va
accepter et il va accepter pourquoi on
est en 92
il découvre que milosevic c'est un type
hays et et d'une certaine manière ça ça
l'intéresse le type pays parce que bien
sûr ici identifie et puis on est sous
l'embargo
c'est la guerre c'est la guerre on
échoue embargo américain et donc les la
puissance publique américaine interdit
aux ressortissants et donc à bobby
fischer d'aller à belgrade
il n'en faut pas plus pour qu'il accepte
5 millions d'euros 5 millions $ toute sa
carrière il va se battre pour un jeu
obtenir à chaque fois des bourges plus
conséquente disant à chaque fois
pourquoi je suis moins bien payés que
mohamed ali
il oublie juste que ça intéresse plus de
monde et que le spectacle a box et le
solde pour lequel on est prêt à payer
les plus grosses sommes n'y a pas
d'équivalent
personne ne payera autant pour aller
voir un film ou un match de basket et où
un championnat d'échecs mais sur la vie
ce il se bat pour lui mais se bat aussi
pour les autres fins il se bat pour la
reconnaissance d échec parce qu'il a un
rapport très compliqué à l'argent ils
gagnent beaucoup d'argent évidemment les
les seuls qui ont une écoute un peu
attentive
c'est l'église universelle de 2 degrés
il va tomber dans les dans les sectes
avec la ferme soit mais c'est quand même
que bobby fischer est juif et il est
antisémite erben antisémite forcené
forcené forcément c'est la figure c'est
comme en littérature un maurice axe quoi
pendant la guerre on lui fait collabos
quoi ça c'est ces figures très très
particulier et au moment de votre livre
commence comme ça quasiment d'ailleurs
puisque il avait été un héros américains
en battant le champion soviétique en 72
pendant la guerre froide et ensuite en
2001 il est celui qui au lendemain des
attentats du 11-septembre dire c'est
bien fait pour les américains et qui
accrédite absolue de tous les complots
sûrement en puissance et de richesse et
les protocoles des sages de sion heavy
aux philippines aux frais de marcos à
leur souffle tout ça ça fait beaucoup
rire les philippins et c'est bon et
quand et quand il ya sept attentats du
world trade center et c'est la voix
discordantes
il est sur radio bonne bouffe le symbole
un nom comme ça il est sûr radiaux
brembo et et et effectivement il prend
fait et cause pour ceux qui ont conduit
ces conduits ces attentats et voilà
c'est déjà lui est retourné aux états
unis depuis
un peu de brume match un peu plus longs
en yougoslavie il aurait fait de la
prison
il peut plus il peut plus rentrer aux
états unis et après ses déclarations
après l'attentât du 11 septembre
là le gouvernement américain est bien
décidée à lui faire payer et mêmes les
paranoïaques ont des ennemis info
fallait le savoir et donc un jour où il
est il est au japon avec avec la
dernière femme avec qui il va vivre
parce que il a toujours cet homme qui
est extraordinairement compliquée il a
quand même toujours fasciné beaucoup de
gens et notamment des femmes notamment
des joueuse d'échecs et elle c'est une
joueuse japonaise très bon très bon
niveau et un jour ils s'apprêtent à
prendre l'avion pour aller aux
philippines et là il est arrêté il va
faire huit mois de huit mois de prison
et est
et selon les autorités de reykjavik les
islandais qui vont le sortir de là lui
donner la nationalité islandaise à la
quasi unanimité du congrès et il va
pouvoir comme ça repartira reykjavik et
mourir arrêter la folie fischer le livre
de christian carisaie est paru aux
éditions alma
[Musique]
céline mazari vous est l'étoile montante
en france du piano classique vous sortez
votre premier album solo consacré aux
variations de beethoven alors pourquoi
beethoven pourquoi pas liste pourquoi
pas mais nelson que vous jouez également
s'il souvent concert mais pourquoi pas
non mais c'est vrai quand on choisit un
album on choisir plutôt un compositeur à
vrai dire ça c'est au détriment d'un
autre
vous devez piocher dans quatre cents 400
ans à peu près de musique vous avez
choisi bétonne j'ai toujours grandi
autour de beethoven moi je suis enfant
il faut savoir quand même que c'est un
compresseur qui a laissé une littérature
assez conséquente
j'adore l'école viennoise j'adore mozart
haydn beethoven c'était une évidence
j'ai hésité un peu entre pas forcément
entre les 3 mai entrée en tout cas on va
dire dans ce style là et puis assez
rapidement j'ai découvert les variations
eroica lorsque j'ai rencontré mon
professeur à vienne qui a été avocat liu
jian et lorsque je les rencontre et j'ai
j'ai eu envie il m'a fait découvrir ces
variations erika et j'ai eu un choc
total pour cette musique
évidemment on connaît beaucoup beaucoup
de choses de beethoven particulièrement
france on connaît surtout les sonata
titre la semaine au clair de lune la
tempête la passionata connaissait
symphonie est alors c'est simple ces
variations héroïque et bien à vrai dire
tout le monde les connaît mais personne
ne le connaît dans le milieu même je
veux dire de duke et les a entendu vous
mais en fait on sait pas ce que c'est
exactement et du coup c'est une
redoutable très dur qui a déjà les
proportions de la période tardive de
beethoven on a tendance à diviser un peu
en trois périodes beethoven donc la
période de jeunes très très proche de
baden mozart deuxième période celle qui
inspire particulièrement les romantiques
c'est à dire la tempête la passionata
c'est vraiment une période très
intéressante est la troisième planète
c'est assez l'ovni total c'est des
espèces d'objets non identifié ça va
être la neuvième symphonie ça va être la
sonata marque la vire ça va être des
espèces de trucs qui sont au début moi
même je peux vous en témoigner alors que
pourtant je suis entre guillemets
professionnels la première édition de
certaines des oeuvres tardives de
beethoven ça m'a vraiment je savais pas
trop comment digérer le truc est alors
cet opus 35 donc c'est au milieu de sa
vie il ya déjà voilà les proportions du
beethoven tardif
donc je me suis dit
on va partir de là et puis on va à
l'appui on va essayer de chercher autre
chose autour et en fait ce qui est
hallucinant avec le principe de la
variation c'est que c'est une forme
super classique c'est une forme bombail
est un thème et 5000 et variées voilà
donc on pourrait se dire il n'y a pas
place à grands grande émotion grands
sentiments grands en fait si avec
beethoven on a affaire à quelqu'un qui
en fait nous montre l'étendue de son
talent l'étendue de son imagination
il travaille surtout il développe tout
dans la variation travail le rythme
travailler les hauteurs de notes ils
travaillent les mélodies il travaille la
technique du piano il ya tout et
finalement c'est presque c'est
pédagogique de ma part de me faire faire
un disque comme ça il ya plus
pédagogique encore c'est le petit film
qui remplace le clip habituels qu'on
voit sur internet
à chaque sortie de disque que vous c'est
carrément un petit film on vous entend
jouer et on vous entend aussi réfléchir
et nous faire profiter de la pédagogie
qui était nécessaire on le regarde on
vous écoute le plus dur en cancer
c'est la tante envie de jouer on a hâte
[Musique]
et on ne peut pas c'est quelque chose
qui échappe à notre contrôle mais
pourtant c'est cette attente
interminable parfum qui génére l'énergie
[Musique]
maintenant tout peut se gérer en amont
on doit tout anticiper sur chaque note
chaque détail chaque mélodie chaque
accompagne on doit vraiment tout pensé
pourquoi parce que je pense qu'un
compositeur comme bétonne est un
architecte c'est indéniable qu'il y a un
sens de la structure qui ne doit pas
nous échapper
[Musique]
c'est une méhari on a parlé beaucoup
d'affrontements dans cette émission il y
en a entre beethoven napoléon bêta
commence par admirer d'apollon en tout
cas il adviendra par le général
révolutionnaire il admire beaucoup moins
napoléon l'autocrate le tyran comme il
l'appelle
ils sont contemporains exactement
beethoven et napoléon et vous insistez
sur le fait à quel point beethoven
moderne
je me demande si c'est pas lui qui est
plus moderne que napoléon juste devant
napoléon c'est un type du xviiie siècle
y croient ils croient pas la démocratie
il a rien compris au nationalisme alors
l'impression de méthode est beaucoup
plus un homme de l'avenir que napoléon
ouais c'est sûr que c'est on pourrait
certains disent que napoléon iv a dit
trahi les la révolution quoi il arrive à
une période très instable politique et
puis il se prend même il se prend à son
propre jeu là le délire des dynasties
dans les pays où c'est exactement il
rétablit l'esclavagé voilà il a aussi
évidemment m'a d'ailleurs c'est ce que
beethoven rejette lorsqu'il écrit donc
la célèbre la la célèbre histoire sur
beethoven qui écrit la symphonie
héroïque berck et en lien avec les le
thème du zen je vous entends pas voilà
le thème est évidemment en fait on
appelle les variations les variations
héroïque plus en lien avec la symphonie
que que beethoven lui même l'aurait
attributs il a juste écrit des
variations mais le thème de l'héroïque
et c'est vraiment réservé à la symphonie
et donc voilà on connaît l'histoire il
écrit une symphonie napoléon bonaparte
puis dès qu'il apprend que napoléon va
de plus en plus vers l'est est lui aussi
devient un conquérant
iway son nom et sur le manuscrit on voit
des ratures mais sert vraiment beaucoup
de ratures il a paru beaucoup
d'application et beaucoup de soin à
supprimer tout tout indice montrant que
c'était napoléon bonaparte et il la
nomme symphonie héroïque carmi bémol
majeur mais pour aider voilà pour ceux
qui savent pas mis un bémol majeur c'est
une tonalité héroïque chez napoléon
c'est la tonalité du concerto l'empereur
entre autres c'est vraiment une c'est
quelqu'un en qui l'avait désire vraiment
il avait beaucoup d'admiration c'est
quelqu'un qui pouvait je pense aussi
avoir des parallèles on bétonne il
arrive à une époque où le langage et à
ses côtés assez classique c'est pour
simplifier quoi et et lui est
extrêmement ambitieux justement dans les
dimensions de sésame donc ça va lui
doivent tout longue les chiots nés lui
vraiment voilà c'était y être 200 euros
mais c'était encore exactement il
termine lorsqu'il termine la semaine
tamer klavier il dit voilà une sonate
qui posera des propos qui posera des
problèmes à des pianistes dans 50 ans je
vais vous dire quelque chose c'est qu'on
est bien
cinquante ans après on aime bien plus
tard et que ça pose ça continue de poser
des problèmes aux pianistes dernière
question celle une méhari quand vous
trouvez la musique actuelles musiques
actuelles voulait dire aujourd'hui la
musique
très sincèrement je pense qu'il faut
avoir beaucoup de temps pour pouvoir
tirer des conclusions sur ce qui ce fait
il ya des choses qui sont géniales qui
se font il ya des choses qui sont nuls
souvent nous on nous évidemment mais ç'a
toujours été le cas même il ya 50 ans et
même il ya 250 ans on a plus souvent des
trucs un peu plus facile et qui
forcément ne feront pas nécessairement
date je fais un métier qui est assez
chronophage et j'ai honte d'admettre que
je connais finalement assez peu de
musiques actuelles
je suis dans la dernière personne qui
peut vous répondre ainsi voilà merci
tous les quatre d'avoir participé à
cette émission le premier album en solo
de céline mazard y est consacré aux
variations de beethoven il en
interprétera trois en concert le samedi
1er février aux folles journées de
nantes
le film d'abdel raouf dafri qu'un sang
impur sort en salles demain galles bio
dano joue la journée de la jupe de jean
paul lilienfeld dans une mise en scène
de frédéric fages au théâtre des béliers
tous les soirs à 21h et christian
carisaie publie la folie fisher sur le
champion du monde de d'échecs bobby
fischer aux éditions alma merci de nous
avoir suivis rendez-vous au prochain
numéro
[Musique]
oui
exempté
certains